when he was killed
uh uh did he get a lot of negative
pushback from the opposing side on why
would you take somebody out that
powerful like i remember once the
this is like the head of the cia fbi you
also got in line yeah and zeller said i
don't know if that was the right move to
make right to do something like that
they're still talking about it they're
still talking about it till today oh
yeah they're not gonna forget about this
guy because this guy had a very
uh
big upside he could have been the face
of the country as a leader to
to to keep
pushing their agenda their philosophies
right
what happens with a situation like this
uh what what's the next
uh uh a could there be a possibility of
a revenge or pushback or the side
effects of doing something like this or
is it more positive for isis to know
listen
if you do anything we're going to
constantly come
and keep doing this to you so yeah is it
a positive move on what happened is
there any negative thing that could
happen here to me it's a hundred percent
positive you know
is there going to be or is there a
potential for blowback revenge of course
there is but that to me you should never
base decisions as to whether or not you
do something based on
on how somebody might uh retaliate based
on that if it's the right you have to
anticipate it though right you should be
anticipating that something could happen
yeah but i i mean i look at it as as
kind of a a net
reaction as far as uh you know if
there's 5 000 capable guys with a you
know combat experience with
strategic value with uh you know
logistical expertise that are within
these organizations it's always better
to remove as many of those people as
possible uh you know irrespective of of
what potential blowback might be i mean
no different than say your company here
like if somebody wanted to take out your
company you know does the thought of you
hiring you know the next best guy or
bringing somebody else in or replacing
whoever is that going to deter them from
trying to to crumble your company no
like they're just going to come at you
harder you know even if you they know
you're going to respond in kind or or
what have you no different than them
you've had a bunch of mob bosses on
similar mentality there is that they're
going to take out who who needs to be
taken out and who's going to be value
value added to being lost by that
organization so yeah i got to tell you i
like this i like that this happened
because
for a minute we seemed sloppy yeah for a
minute we seemed weak for a minute it
was like you know these guys can't
handle anything i love the fact that
something like this happened forget
who's in the white house it's great that
america is seen with some like this
taking place now it's tragic when you
read it and saying because look how this
one wrote it this one wrote it let's say
right there on the article it says the
syrian civil defense first responders
alhamdulillah at least 13 people died
including six children and shelling in
clashes that followed the raid right
yeah so you read that and it doesn't
look positive it looks negative
british monitoring group the syrian
observatory for human rights that at
least nine people were killed and
thursday's strike but we don't two
children and a woman but you don't know
if he'd kill those kids we don't know
who those two are those those his kids
because on wikipedia says he killed
himself right he blew himself up i'd be
kirsten as information comes in to see
uh what that situation was like
uh in syria mike um
years ago i mean a handful of years ago
we all we would hear about was the
syrian civil war i remember when gary
johnson the libertarian party was
running for president this was in 2016
when when trump won and and obviously
edged out hillary clinton he completely
[ __ ] the bed because they said what are
your thoughts on what's going on with
aleppo
right and he was like what's up he's
like what's a lappo it's like brother
you want to be president you don't know
the capital of syria what the hell are
you talking about right now and that guy
was done um but what is going on in
syria these days we heard so much about
assad chemical warfare on their citizens
uh you know isis you know it's so like
you have you have isis and then you have
the taliban in afghanistan and then you
have syria and the dictators and like
the shiites and the sunnis and these
people and then the kurds up there it's
we can't figure out who to kill and then
syrian the government is fighting isis
but we're fighting isis but we're also
against assad
we don't hear a lot about it this is the
pat's point what just can you make some
sense of it or is there no way to make
sense of what to do going over there
well being a part-time janitor at the
cia let me tell you what's going on
i mean the short answer is is it's not
as involved as it was you know four
years ago is it still a mess the same
way a lot of places uh
are still a mess over there yes
you know to try to to dissect it and
understand uh you know the cause and
effect and and what is really going on i
mean to me you really need to spend time
there
um you know and
try to evaluate it from a almost from a
journalist standpoint of of not taking
sides and just there figuring out what
what that is
why there's not more attention paid to
it i think just really stems from the
fact that afghanistan uh you know heated
up with with the the draw down and then
the the debacle of the
of the withdrawal from there as well as
you know iran getting
nuclear material and and you know things
happening between
israel and
in palestine the same way that that it
has you know for the last several years
and so it's
there's just so many different things
going on there that are all kind of
equally terrible
you know i wouldn't say that it's
necessarily any worse than
seven other places over there it's just
you're not hearing about it because
there's there's no reason to hear about
it there's not an election going on we
have almost no involvement over there
and so it's just not on the radar
especially with you know something like
covid
uh here making such a big deal out of
that it's just uh it's a priority thing
and is isis still as powerful or though
they're not anywhere no they're nowhere
near as powerful do they still exist yes
i mean there's a faction there's isis k
in afghanistan that's caused a lot of
problems but
um you know to me they're
they're smaller than they used to be
mostly the four years that trump was in
office of really getting getting after
it from an offensive standpoint as
opposed to to a reactive standpoint in
what way
just i mean
[Music]
operations like this
times a thousand you know there there
was a lot more troop presence there
uh you know we we took a lot of
intelligence-based uh measures to to
execute missions like this and and other
ones to to push them back and take
territory back and and get rid of high
value targets and things of that nature
so if you enjoyed this little short
segment from the podcast that we did
here's another short segment to watch or
if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you